I feel when it comes to at all it's easy
for people to look in from the outside
but when you when you put it all
together
sorry I'm late I just don't give oh not
just a way it's not just a fight all of
the other stuff the damn right to see in
the UFC stands for Conor she's a [__]
I'm getting five chicks out there more
chicks as far as the fight he will be
unconscious inside for hours
July 14th 1988 Conor McGregor's born a
little baby Conor McGregor the exact and
he come up with some other with clenched
fists according to his dad who said he'd
always been a fighter his mom wasn't
able to see that she was a bit busy at
the time but he was born and raised in
Crumlin which is sort of known for being
a bit of a rough city but the local say
it is fine don't worry about it as a kid
Connor seemed like any other Irish lad
you know loved football
supported money naked but when he turned
12 that was where his love of fighting
started that was when young Connor would
walk in the Crumlin boxing club and this
is where would meet a man called Phil
Sutcliff now Phil would then become his
boxing coach and he was the one who
taught Conor house which dances and a
lot of the skills that would eventually
meet Connor and nightmare for everyone
but unfortunately for Connor at 17 his
family would move to Lucan which was
considered to be a more desirable area
but for him that meant leave in the gym
and with that all of his friends now
many people know Connors dad in MMA Tony
is a charismatic dude he is a sharp
dresser but what they might not know is
but in the day he was a hard-working man
I mean he was taxi driver and he was a
hospital orderly and he encouraged
contact to go and get himself an honest
job
Connor ended up in a plumbing
apprenticeship which meant every morning
he'd be waiting by the side of the
motorway they got picked off ticket the
site and installing pipes we drive two
hours in the traffic all the way that I
say and it was just a rough time for me
and I kneeled it I did not want to
pursue this lightly so I left and I quit
and I went home and I told my father I
said there's not a hope in hell you're
gonna ever get me back on that build and
say again it got to the point where his
dad goes up the stairs he's throwing
money at him please go do your
apprenticeship go to college and I'll
give you ten grand
you offered him ten grand to do it he
turns this quilt over
nah I'm not going it's not for me it's
rumoured at that point
Tony McGregor caught pretty hungry and
he essentially said we'll see about that
and we
many many fail though I may have lost
the fights the fights we had but
essentially I warned because I did not
go back to the build and say no as you
can imagine Conner was pretty
disillusioned I mean we know the man now
he wasn't gonna settle from that
lifestyle let's be honest so he really
needed someone to turn to and the man II
told you was John Kavanagh now he first
met John at 15 years old when he walked
it was Jim and Paddy hula and said he
rocked up with a crazy haircut boxer
shorts on and a boxers angry face he
wasn't there to become part of the
family he wanted to compete he wanted to
fight with a bit of sparring and a bit
of grinding from John Kavanagh they work
that would understand and that they
could really help each other a lot the
more Conor went to the gym and learned
Mme
the more he wanted to go whereas it was
the exact opposite with work you mean he
had no interest in becoming a plumber at
all Conor then threw himself completely
into the sport of MMA he had his first
fight I mean he rocked up and beat short
but he still beat the living hell out of
the other guys and the power is clear as
day to say in that first video second
fight the confidence is coming now the
movement is coming he is growing as a
fighter every day he meets his idol
Chuck Liddell at UFC 85 in London things
could be going back from a career
standpoint but behind the scenes it's
still not looking good
[Applause]
in his next fight karna would lose by
submission which definitely brought them
down a peg or two then things went from
bad to worse Connor took some tickets
that were set aside for John Cavanaugh
sold them spent the money on himself
which basically meant he was stealing
from his own coach it came out karna
wouldn't even face John Kavanagh he was
so ashamed of what he'd done he'd barely
got out of bed the only way this
relationship was repaired was by Donna's
mom going and begging John Cavanaugh
please give him another chance and
that's what got Connor back in the game
now we've all seen the relationship John
and Connor have I mean they're like
brothers you know but it feels like this
point in their relationship was the
turning point after reading this Court
which says his mother was worried her
name was Margaret my mother's Margaret
too and it was one of the first times
maybe the first time that a parent had
reached out to me it got me thinking
maybe I've got a bigger role here than
punching and kicking maybe I'm doing a
bit more for them than I thought and I
guess I started to realize that a lot of
people get into fighting for the same
reasons I did it's not for the fight
they are dealin with something in their
childhood called a pitch John off so
John just pinned him down pummeled the
[__] up I mean and promised he was there
to learn to fight and not for street one
the [__] is everyone looks at Conor
McGregor now has missed a success in
fighting he's got so much money but then
he was a bum like he couldn't even
afford training gear and he needed
someone to partner him on this journey
and they say behind every successful man
as an even better woman that to me was a
special thing to be able to do my my
girlfriend worked very very hard and
throughout the years coming up and stood
by me when essentially I had absolutely
not them she's tall she's brunette she's
beautiful she's got like a girl next
door face and like a really nice smile
she's got hips on her but she's slim and
she's in Grich it like despite Connor
being such an outspoken nasty piece of
work Italian she calms him she is the
warmth the care and the love when he is
acting outrageous you know she seems
like the type of us who you could be all
ready to fight and rip someone's head
off and she could just calm you right
down no problem so the first time you
Cesar gets our attention in the
nightclub starts crackin the job so
you're not getting a laugh and as you do
she gets home next morning wakes up
friend requests from
Conor McGregor smooth color real smooth
before you know it days moved into the
house with Connors mom and dad in a
stand with Connor 24/7 she's helping him
with her money from her job she's
looking after him and everywhere
possible she's picking him to the gym as
a taxi service she's cooking for hours
cleaning for she is his confidence now
karna battled so long training hard
every day getting the [__] [__]
kicked out of him and then his dad not
believing in his dream and feeling like
he'd let him down he finally had someone
who was gonna support them all the way
and that must have made a massive
difference you know like you're sitting
yourself saying I can be world champion
one day and everyone thinks you're crazy
now finally someone that you love and
leaves that as well and they would often
speak about this on the car journeys to
the gym and speak their future into
existence one day he's not gonna have to
work and I'm going to be world champion
and everything is going to happen just
like this and it did
I'm a professional MMA fighter with a
record of 4 and 1
and I'm an up-and-coming fighter and
without a doubt you will see me on the
UFC and in their future whatever their
but it wasn't easy
McGregor went on an absolute tear in
Cage Warriors not out after not out
after not out people were dropping like
flies around this guy and this
culminated in the lightweight title
fight against Yvonne Bosch inga where he
butted him and finished him with a
devastating trademark mcgregor left hook
that left conor mcgregor a to wit will
chug in and cage warriors and on top of
the world it seemed but in reality he
still didn't have a lot of money one of
his best mates are being told some very
bad medical news after fighting for too
long and the UFC still hadn't called the
dream was still a mile away and then I
was an island except in the gold medal
of honorary patronage from Trinity
College where everyone he met said when
are you gonna say in Conor McGregor he
was like who he pretty soon became aware
of who god I'm aggregor was got the
meeting together and not long after that
meeting he calls the rose over Tito and
says look I don't know if this kid can
fight but if he can we've got a border
fight stop on my hands with his life so
after sitting on the door for a few
months and feeling like [__] about
himself because no one feels good on the
doors to us set me uncle because he's a
lazy bastard Conor McGregor was finally
gonna make his ways of the UFC against
Marquez premature was gnawin
too bad I'm gonna try and take his
[__] head off Cora gets in there and
we see movement like we've never seen in
the USA we've seen good strikers before
but the angles that he's coming in at
and the uppercuts and the shots he was
throwing
we had not seen that style before and
Marcus per image was in way over his
head in Makkah swimmers was good but
McGregor was he looked like Neil from
the matrix in there he couldn't be
touched and he just smashed the slides
of bits and announced himself on the
world stage in his first fight he got a
knockout of the night and he instantly
connected with the crowd which is
something no one has done better than
him when he shouted a day in our way 60
G's very and that's what he wanted
and that's what he got from dinner he
instantly had control over dinner or the
UFC over the crowd and over the fight
and he's never stopped doing that from
that first fight next up it was max
Holloway who's gone on to become a world
champion but this fight came way too
soon in his career for him Connor was on
a level above in every single facet of
Mme he controlled and dominated this
fight even with an injury the problem is
we didn't realize how big of an injury
it was and after the fight it came out
the Conor had ruptured his ACL which
brought his UFC dream to a grinding halt
I remember that time in the USC vividly
because the UFC had been putting so much
energy behind this kid and all of a
sudden he's gone and we don't know if
he's coming back we don't know if he's
going to be as good as he was when he
comes back by all accounts from the
doctors he competed obsessively with
George st. Pierre on his recovery
because George Sibley had the exact same
injury and every day it's what a Georges
do how did George do this
did George do that this quickly he
wanted to beat George Butler the Octagon
even when he was recovering from an
injury it was all a competition and when
he did come back he came back with a
vengeance
[Music]
and his comeback fight Conner was
matched up against a hard Brazilian
bastard in Diego Brandao he was a man no
one wanted to fight he looked evil on
the Ultimate Fighter then they put it in
Dublin Ireland just don't rub the
pressure up more it's in his own
backyard so that's the first time in a
main event on the UFC legal brand I was
staring across the kid from him in his
own backyard and it's his comeback fight
where he has to remind everyone who he
is he doesn't want anyone to forget
Conor McGregor is the rising star in the
UFC and how does he deal with all that
pressure he runs across the cage and
beats the [__] [__] out of them he
makes him look like an amateur and he
lets the whole world know we're not yet
a cake pop but he had a cake over next
look it's a tough [__] in Dustin
Poirier and we've only really realized
how good this kid is since the fight
because everyone else has said they're
absolute hands full with him but before
the fight Connor is baiting him winding
him up getting him over emotional making
him on a run and take Ana's head off
because when he does that he forgets the
gameplan
if it gets the technique coming up again
to me that's not gonna be good and I'm
gonna crack him with a jab and he's
gonna wobble and I'm gonna put him away
early it's gonna be a first round KO
mark my words
I don't works a charm Connor predicts
the first round knockout which seemed a
little bit unrealistic of the time but
pouria walks on to every big shot
because Connor is in his head we're
seeing for the first time really the
main games of Conor McGregor he lands a
big shot just as he predicted finishes
Dustin Poirier in the first round and
this was the fight that earned Connor
the nickname mystic muck
[Applause]
you can call me mythic Mac because I
predict eating now was the chance for
Connor to seize his title shot
all you had to do was beat dennis siver
which seemed like an easy matchup on
people I mean the blog is nowhere near
the size of McGregor and McGregor made
easy work of them the most entertaining
thing about the fight came after it when
Connor jumped the cage stairs right in
the face of Jersey Aldo in the crowd and
screams into his face he lets him know
right there and then there is no fear
and that was the first time we'd ever
seen anyone act like that the words
Georgie our door Aldo was undefeated for
10 years he was feared by everyone no
one wanted to fight Josie Aldo and Conor
made it a massive statement they and
saying I'm coming for you spit shine in
that [__] belt pub the main games
kana played in Orono that I fight took a
massive toll on Josie and it literally
started the second he finished fight in
tennis even that really shows what a
genius and a master tactician McGregor
had been in the art of fight so Dana
makes the fight Josie Aldo Brazilian
jiu-jitsu blackbelt muy Thai specialist
an absolute animal undefeated for 10
years against a wild man from Ireland
who can't start knocking people over
[Applause]
they went on a world tour where Conor
relentlessly pushed him shoved them
touched him ripped his belt off of did
everything he could get into that man's
mind and it seemed like it worked
because not long before the fight was
meant to happen
Aldo pulls out with an injury now that
injury was a pretty bad injury but
Connor had worse injuries at the time
his ACL was not again and it really
seemed like Khan had finally gotten into
his head just where he wanted to in
steps Chad Mendes on a matter of days
notice a wrestling specialist Tyler
Connor had supposedly been protected
from the whole entire time had now been
given a chance against Connor while
Connor had a knee injury which is the
worst kind of injury can have and trying
to stop a takedown so we were gonna say
finally how Connor does against the
wrestler that fight for me was possibly
one of my most memorable as a McGregor
farm because he was such an underdog you
know now everyone looks at him is this
big wealth machine but in this fight
he'd never won a title you know can he
do it can this kid from Ireland the
ultimate underdog finally pull off the
upset
can he beat a wrestler who is being
protected against and he tries to get
into Chad Mendes his mind he's saying
who's gonna take the first step back
it'll not be me let's go and meet in the
middle let's fight it out and Mendes is
obviously gonna wrestle he's trying to
get him not here he goes straight out of
Hawaiian kicks Mendes takes them down
and he spends a lot of that first two
rounds on his back trying to get up but
as he promised before the fight he used
elbows he is hammering Chad Mendes from
the bottom when he gets off he is
picking a shot he is stabbing him with
kicks to the belly trying to get the
energy out of Mendes because he hadn't
had those longer come as McGregor when
he finally weathers the storm he gets up
at the end of the second round he
promised in our way I'm gonna end this
in the second round and he marches
forward Mendes tries to take him down
again but he can't this time Mendes is
tired it's all paying off for Conor
stubborn kicks punches he will be
stopped
left right left and the massive overhand
left rots Chad Mendes he's on the floor
Connors covered in blood
he's beltram it's all over the new UFC
featherweight champion Conor McGregor
he's on top of the cage with John
Cavanaugh the journey all that
friendship all that training all that
respect that they have has finally
culminated
in World Championship gourd live bunny
Connor drops to his knees and you can
see he is physically emotionally
absolutely exhausted like he's given his
whole life for this moment and it's
finally here everyone who loves hims
around him all his training partners his
family as co-chair all celebrating
because he's world champion and the
Irish people have invaded that part of
the world and they've turned that whole
part of Vegas Irish for one night only
it was a dream come true the problem is
the dream wasn't fully realized because
he's not actually world champion is the
interim champion and Jersey Aldo is
still officially the world champion so
he knows he's got to go after him next
Jozy Aldo is the pound-for-pound King
everyone rates him as the best fighter
at anyway class but Gregor does seem to
be under a skin and as the week's
build-up to this fight he rubs the
pressure back upon him he is calling him
every name trying to get into his skin
to make him over emotional he even
admits it right before the fight he's
like I just wanted to all the commits
leave himself in the dead space and I
will be there setting traps in a
frightened Center and he will realize he
is in trouble by then it is truly and he
says it exactly like that even on the
war pians you can see the difference in
attitude McGregor doesn't look like he's
in a world title fight he looks like
it's going to walk their dog down the
beach I'll door looks like he's about to
get executed for crimes he did ten years
ago I mean he's literally just like
walking towards like that it looks bad
you know I mean he doesn't look
confident but all those known to not be
the most braggadocious guy walking into
the fight so you saw everything oh well
that doesn't maybe mean anything they go
to touch gloves they don't touch those
there's bad blood there but even then
there's no eye contact
McGregor is looking him dead in the eye
but Aldo is looking at the ground he is
annoying rest in that pool right before
they fight McGregor looks across the
ring and he says to Aldo let's go boy
and the fact that he says that before
he's about to fight the most feared
fighter in MMA shows he knew what was
going to happen he had spent hours upon
hours knowing that he was one day going
to fight this
many years ago analyzing the sky and
knows every weakness he has and he knows
he's gonna be there Aldo walks our
over-aggressive over and over extends
all over 13 seconds was all it took
and before we know it MacGregor's on the
cage and he's giving it all are
celebrating because now he's the
undisputed world champion it's that
point in MMA
it didn't feel like we had the next big
star on my hands it felt like we had a
phenomena in MMA the fact that he called
the first round not of a man who'd never
been beaten in 10 years went in and
didn't just knock him out in the first
round you know I'm not the first 15
second I mean that is insane the hype
train not only was it on it was on full
steam ahead
Conor McGregor had announced himself as
the biggest star in MMA history and that
might've been one of the worst things
that happened to Connor not to be older
but to beat him so easily and harvests
Tartikoff so much he went from an MMA
start to a superstar and everyone in the
world now knew Conor McGregor and that
definitely when it was hell I mean you
see in the press conferences later on
where he is just crazy like there's no
other way to describe it you know we've
seen him go from joking and knowing that
he's joke into like the courage I just
drew it was almost like the mass he put
on that mask and boom he just turned
into this monster you know and is
entertaining as it was so leaving your
own hype is a dangerous thing is the
talent that this Connor was that one
shot kill that he landed on Aldo made
him think he could do that any
one-on-one person he couldn't do that
who was Nate Diaz
[Applause]
now the fight against Nate Diaz came
about because he was supposed to be
fighting rafael dos anos he pulled out
and last minute Conner said [__] it I'll
fight anyone which you have to respect
that Nate Diaz puts his hand up and next
thing you know we've got these two going
at each other now they're already made
perfect match and that they both
aggressive [__] but because
Conor not know Georgie Aldo was Ezz hard
I think he just thought I'm gonna go in
there and do the same Nate Diaz Aldo is
a better fighter than Nate Diaz
technically yes but I was a much smaller
man Nate Diaz is a much bigger man
honey's [__] fixed I mean he does
triathlons for chrissake this guy can go
and even on short notice probably is
fitter than Conor McGregor Hana turns up
looking like he's bout to go at the
beach you know he's a lot heavier than
he usually is and he's not used to
carrying that much size and mass during
a fight and managing to go the distance
you know this was a totally new
experience for him let alone fighting
someone who's over six foot he haven't
prepared for this at all but he's
thinking [__] I'm Conor McGregor and
knock people out who have been unbeaten
in ten years in the first round I didn't
do this no you can't when he went into
the fight his men are doing was he did
not take media seriously he did not
realize he was fighting a 6 foot 1 or 6
foot 2 zombie who was gonna take his
shot and keep moving forward
and actually slip a lot of them as well
because that lanky dude is good at using
the shoulder all style and Conor was
really not accurate not efficient with
his energy I missed a lot of his big
chances and the ones he did like the
earth just sucked it up got on it like
and that pressure took its toll and next
thing you know what I'm breathing heavy
they're not our power is gone good night
ideas is in his face punching punching
next thing you know Conor McGregor the
strike and expert is shooting for his
life and Nate Diaz has got him wrapped
up like an anaconda on the floor and
it's choking the [__] life elders of
the height trained well and truly be
reeled this was weirdly one of the most
impressive moments of Madonna's career
because after all the [__] top and in
all the bravado
he'd been humiliated in the middle of
the Octagon and you wondered how he's
going to deal with this is he gonna do a
run Darren hide under a towel and not
even be seen leaving the arena but no he
got up dusted himself off and took it
like a man and said look I've been
bested I'm gonna come back and I want
that man at that same way nor
changes again cuz I can beat him yeah I
went in I told I took the fight and it
didn't pay off this is the fight
business it's another day I'll come back
and the fact that he was so honest
towards himself it made you realize why
he's become such a good fighter because
the only people who improve are the ones
who can criticize themselves and become
their own biggest critic and you can
really say that in him he really didn't
have a problem with what anyone else
said it was how he felt about himself
inside that really mattered I knew knew
he was gonna go away and try and like an
absolute [__] and that's exactly
what he did he spent a fortune on his
train and car bringing in lumpy boxers
with the same stance as the US to
replicate the style he really prepared
for this next fight and it was all
business now
now his reputation was on the line
because if he goes and loses to Diaz
again then this invincible superhuman
character that we've all bought in who
is finished I mean he's gatekeeper at
that point because Nate Diaz didn't have
an amazing reputation before McGregor
got beaten off him anyway so he had to
win this fight that minty and the brand
everything and he knew he had to bet on
himself and bet big and he did this was
the biggest fight in the UFC so far even
the music that came out new Connor had
biggie Nate had to park they were just
the perfect rivalry in every way in our
first round we've seen when they're
fresh who was the better fighter
McGregor or the full gas tank just
looked a level above Diaz clipping him
left right and centre chopping him down
with the leg kicks dropping him and in
the second round he dropped the edge
twice you wondered why didn't he just go
to the ground and finish him but you
don't want to go down there with an
octopus like this he will pull you in
and tie up and before you know it you're
getting choked out again so on the
Greger plays have safe was the end of
the second round we see Diaz getting a
bit more energy you know McGregor as he
does eight minutes that 8 minute mark
for whatever reason it seems to be a
wall that here to the gas tank in the
third round it was all deal and Diaz is
piling the pressure on column out the
commentators Joe Rogan is thinking it's
all Diaz Diaz has got him in a lot of
trouble
McGregor table at the users shoulders
and the shots are bouncing off from left
right and centre against the cage we're
thinking we're seeing a better version
of Conor but still not good enough
to beat the us the as looks like he's
coming on strong at this point and that
he's gonna have the gas tank to finish
Connor but Connor clearly prepared
better for this than what people had
realized because in the fourth round he
gets another wind and all of that card
your train and that he'd been doing paid
off he puts the pressure on Diaz he's
out landing him time and time again and
that puts him three rounds to one and in
the fifth round Connor
costed that one no one really asserted
their dominance that much but Diaz did
get a takedown but it wasn't here it was
a closed room and it Connor I did enough
to get the win and he showed really at
that point
despite the other size advantage he is
the bear fighter Cora had once again
come back from adversity for what feels
like the millionth time in this journey
and now we had his sights on that
lightweight title he wanted to be the
first UFC fighter ever to hold two
titles at the same time no one had ever
done that before and standing in his way
was Eddie Alvarez now they call Eddie
Alvarez the underground King for a
reason he is a fighters fighter he has
got the respect of everyone he is a hard
man but he can do everything in MMA to a
good standard you're not gonna walk
through Eddie Alvarez with ease or so we
thought but Connor did it again just
when you think we can't outdo himself he
goes in there and he makes Eddie Alvarez
look like a [__] child
I don't even say I have a big fan of
Eddie Alvarez but he did he went in
there and it was possibly the biggest
well it was the biggest fight of his
life that was the biggest UFC history
moment we've probably ever seen and he
made him look like a [__] kid and he
takes a shot well but when Colin landed
that punch the first paunchy land you've
seen a look on Eddie Alvarez his face
like what the [__] was that that is not
what we I've never had anything like
that me like you could tell and it just
landed - over and over and over again
and before we hear it others have been
down like three times when Alvarez went
for the shot and tried for the takedown
any field I was watching it live and
even at that point that was that this is
over you know you're only [__] hope
what's the [__] land I take down me
if you can't do that good night it felt
like a matter of time and there was a
kid
when in how is Connor gonna abuse not it
and this for punch combo about United we
don't see [__] like this anyway this was
high level boxing and Eddie Alvarez his
head is a [__] pinball machine yummy
he's all over this job person drops him
it's all over the first time the UFC has
ever been in New York and we've got
Conor McGregor just as he predicted
holding two titles at one time mystic
Mac mix MMA history but if there's one
thing we've learned about this book is
that it's never enough nothing is ever
enough one belt in cage warius wasn't
enough he needed to Bane and cage
warriors wasn't enough he needed to be
in the UFC being UFC champion wasn't
enough he wanted two belts now belts on
enough being Mme superstar of all time
isn't enough he wants to fight the
biggest star in combat sports history
Floyd money Mayweather there's no one I
weigh about it his little legs is little
car I'm gonna knock him out inside four
rounds mark my words
Oh work is what weight you the easy work
there
[Music]
and he thinks he can beat him at his own
game a game Mayweather has studied for
decades upon decades and Connor's just
gonna walk right in beat him in his
first match she's never even bossed
I mean he's boxed in a cage for boxing
in the cage when he defended to take
them before ours gloves are nothing like
wearing the gloves that they have and
beaten someone who was spent a lifetime
in practicing how to block punches so
every boxing expert McGregor is in way
over his head even the most MMA fight
but every time we've dealt with him he's
always proven wrong and there's a part
of you that no matter how unrealistic
it seems can't help but believe you may
have a [__] chance here he may just
connect and boom maybe it's someone who
isn't a boxer who's gonna be the
underdog for Floyd Mayweather
you won't say a common it'll be a weird
wild child Norway and nutty on the whole
world buys into this fight
it's superstar versus superstar the best
in boxing this is the best in MMA the
two biggest [__] talk as in history and
they're all about the money they're
gonna make a fortune off of this fight
if you're asking what I like to fight
Floyd I mean who would not like to dance
around the ring I'll be honest before
the fight I said like an eighth round
stoppage - Floyd mir-1 that is the only
way I can see it happening he's gonna
defend McGregor we're gonna see McGregor
tire and then mirror that's gonna have
all been season on Conor that's pretty
much how it went but the closer the
fight got the more you just start of her
leave and before I know it I'm putting
hundreds of pounds out of those press
conferences were probably the most
memorable thing about that fight I mean
they were Abby Connor fainted ambushed
on the first one he had no idea that it
wasn't like an MMA press conference
where people ask questions and you
answer them he was there on the podium
just [__] rumbling do you know
anybody he did speak very confidently
and said I'm gonna knock them out inside
the first four rounds this is an old
Marny husband got what it takes to hire
on my power and I you know you starting
to believe that I mean he is an older
man you know how can you stand the power
of Conor and then when they face off
McGregor really starts trying to get
into his head down he's like you're
lucky this isn't a real fight you'd be
dead already
your little all of Harlan's hurt and
these days other you got brittle bones
of you you just start believing yeah
he's gonna drag him into a real fight
you know he's gonna meet and fight them
and Connors gonna catch him in the
second press conference Conor
brought his [__] team I want this
entire leader to scream don't make
letters to tree that's what I remember
from that [__] press conference
it was unbelievable Troy turns up with
the track suit on in like a Louis
Vuitton bag and McGregor I was like what
you've got a school bag on stage you
can't even leave
this was like a stand-up comedy session
really more than a press conference uh
no fighter in the history of the game
even Muhammad Ali couldn't talk [__]
like that
that was another level and at that point
I think everyone was like when you're
watching someone verbally destroying
someone else no matter the skills the
sports the records you can't have the
things he must be at the kicks that
sauce subliminally it just sinks Sydney
a brain and he made people buy into this
fight and that was why everyone cave by
the time the gloves were on the problem
was not a [__] boxer you know he's an
MMA fighter and for old kana has got
some really good natural boxing skills
and he landed Mayweather played the
perfect game plan as I thought he
probably would absorb the energy early
on made sure that all the heaviest shots
McGregor was gonna throw were bouncing
off him and once a McGregor had spent
that energy then me rather walk them
down truthfully I think if McGregor had
actually tried to counter punch instead
of going in there and bully me on that
he might have had a much about a chance
in land in that one shot despite giving
up a lot of rounds but we'll never know
the bottom line is is me whether I was a
better boxer than Conor McGregor but
what McGregor did sure he does deserve
credit for as he got in there with the
greatest of all time
all right a little over the hill and
lasted ten rounds in his first ever
boxing match against Floyd Mayweather
that deserves respect
even though McGregor lost a fight his
stock didn't drop everyone thought faith
play he got in any hardcore and he did
land some punches early on but now
everyone wants a buck in MMA lots proven
harder than we thought we've gone from
saying McGregor month-in month-out
always in the media something's happened
and he's fighting soon two months of
nothing and only lately has he come up
with the shadows after months away from
the sport and being stripped the both of
his titles Conor finally showed his face
at a UFC event the night before his
lightweight title was due to be computed
for by khabib nurmagomedov no khabib had
recently got into an altercation with
his good friend art and low above Connor
took that as a personal insult he flies
over with a mob full of Irish lads and
he attacks curbs bus smashing a dolly
through the window injuring UFC fighters
demand and khabib get off the [__]
bus
Kabir doesn't get off the
Connor goes on the run and the NYPD end
of tracking him down
Connor is charged with one count of
criminal mischief and three counts of
assault and is likely to get the very
least anger management and a big fight
it could be worse
this is a massive setback the Connors
career because now he's been known for
all of the wrong things you know winning
fights is what got him the name he's got
not smashing bosses oh and when the fame
got to him last time it was the Diaz
loss that brought him back down to earth
and made him work harder than he ever
had before to bring the best out winner
and I hope that this does the same thing
because if it doesn't we're going to see
one of the most talented UFC fighters
ever blue as it stands Conor McGregor is
on bail until June 14 2008 Ian where
does he go from here let me know in the
comments
there will be more profiles like this
coming to the channel so if you like
this hit the like button subscribe
thanks for watching and I'll see us
later
[Music]
you